we're about to do something new right
now we have a mystery guest here on the
wrap-up show I'm not gonna lie I'm
nervous I never get nervous doing the
show ever
right but I've been told I don't know
this man I'm told that I'm a fan so Gary
I'll let you do the introduction we'll
get right to it Rashaan you're always
bitching about the Beatles And you say
that Earth Wind and Fire is your did you
get something from Earth Wind and Fire
in here founding member Ralph Johnson
would like to come in and say hello holy
holy gosh I gotta stand up real
quick sir I'll take it away oh you're
here if you don't mind I I need I need
to greet this man
Rashad's getting up to give him a big
hug he's very excited like I said this
is uh this is rasan's beetles so Ralph
you should know that rasan is just an
enormous enormous fan of the band huge
really huge fan come on tell the truth
huge fan I I grew up listening to Earth
Wind and Fire because as you know your
musical tastes are are uh influenced by
the people that uh raised you my dad
played you guys all the time all the
time I play I play running everything
every week every week of my life every
week of my life the the instrumental the
harmonies I I just I just love you guys
so much and on this show uh I I just I
talk about it all the time how
Earth Wind and Fire is the greatest band
of all time I think the music you guys
put out has changed people's lives and
you guys are just just icons so you're
very kind thank you so you know what I
tell people in interviews we've been
very blessed yeah and we have
you know man look I was a guy playing
right over here on Crenshaw Boulevard at
a club called Mavericks flat I know
exactly where that is well 42-25
Crenshaw yeah and uh Maurice and Verdine
uh saw me play with this band down there
and next thing I knew I was getting a
phone call and they they asked me if I
wanted to audition that was December of
71. and and then by 72 Clive Davis had
seen us and signed us immediately to
Columbia Records and man that started
that started the whole thing you know it
was uh it was crazy